hello there I'm Gavin down where the
slow mo guys Dan what would you say so
much interesting natural disaster I'm
quite impressed by things like tornadoes
like wildfire
what should we sort of combine the two
melting pot the fire tornado is actually
surprisingly a naturally occurring event
pretty rare very awesome pretty awesome
so we're gonna recreate it with that
twelve box bands in a circle and some
fire okay so we've got about a half an
inch of kerosene in there it's gonna
light it step back and let it build up
and then we'll turn the fans on okay all
right I'm ready on a phantom here we go
yeah that's lit okay just let it build
up
go for it yep
ten further
hi-yah
yes
it wasn't high enough look at that it's
literally a perfect fold
well then I'm not being funny that
looked phenomenal yeah
looks amazing isn't it I'm always
waffling on about how liquids and flame
looks good
spinning flame even better I think from
now on all flames should be spinning
yeah it looked so good I just wanted to
eat it was it did look good not so
smooth no I wanted to eat fire before
yeah looks so nice all right did you get
singed actually for once I didn't losing
the arm hair no eyebrows and hair
nothing I was right we played it slappy
with that feel free to follow us on
Twitter buy a shirt thank you very much
for watching yeah see you next time